the average inmate stops receiving
visitors within a few years of arriving
in prison but 10 years later George's
mother still makes the three-hour trip
from her home in New Orleans
Frances started off with to give it a
month if this trip is just so hard on me
once I get home through once I get home
I'm drained so then I cut it down to
once a month I'm doing time waiting
we both doing the time together that's
why I say I'll be glad when this is over
and with France and I do know it's gonna
be over you know it might take a while
but George is gonna get out of this I'm
doing it again all right how you doing
well I lied I'm getting to the point now
I'm getting kind of used to it now just
when I get here my heart beat there's
you know but I'm excited because I know
must see him but it's hard because
George is the baby of the bunch I had
seven children I got full living and
George was the baby I never did uphold
my kids none of my kids have if there's
something and I know they did I would
admit to it but I don't deeply believe
in my heart I still believe he didn't do
this after years of progressing toward
trustee status and its privileges George
is accused of being part of a gambling
ring and is sent to the hole where
contact visits are prohibited
I wish you wouldn't can the big what's
up
somebody put a knife upstairs somebody
put a knife planted an iPhone not on me
it was upstairs
I don't like seeing you like this it's
the second time I'm knocked up babe I
understand how people just keep setting
you up I just don't share mom I don't
know at the same like when I try to do
right things go wrong but when I go
wrong things go right bang no more rules
rules when you know you get a person
didn't build the dirty hands
that's that ain't no rules heartbreak
and I'm staring
ain't no doubt comedy no every time I
come in if your own lockdown out its
catch me by surprise all the time ten
years fifteen years ten years later look
around me two years later
[Music]
it might be over for me I said I'd never
give up give up hope but it might be
that might be a sign all this happening
that is over it's over charge is over
for you everybody gone you don't know
why
it's gonna be alright you know don't
ever lose hope you keep freeing it like
I told you just keep praying perhaps
open doors that's got to be free
[Music]